what's going on guys
Warcraft the movie inspired by Warcraft
and World of Warcraft the online games
is hitting theaters are you excited
about it if you're like me you don't
know a lot about Warcraft so today
that's why we're asking our guests to
please explain craft and we have an
awesome couple of folks to talk about
Warcraft with us first she's a writer on
MTV's upcoming Mary and Jane and she's
co-host of the bunker buddies podcast
and she's actually producing a
documentary about World of Warcraft
Andy bolt he is a writer for Comedy
Central's @midnight and he's the co-host
man this is serious nerd cred he's the
co-host of a Dragonball Z podcast called
Crillon it with Effie and Danny if you
watt away thanks for being here man
first off right off the bat Warcraft
what's the difference between Warcraft
and world of warcraft world Warcraft
takes place after Warcraft oh it takes
place in a world called Azeroth am I
correct on that and I imagine when I
picture Warcraft orcs versus humans an
epic battle uh tell me about that is it
all orcs first humans the thing that's
kind of cool is that I never played
Warcraft I've only played World of
Warcraft and so for me as a World of
Warcraft player I feel like it's almost
like a prequel to the game I've been
enjoying because it's kind of the story
about how the orcs came to Ezra and you
know when you play World of Warcraft you
start in a world where there's all these
like spaceships that have just crashed
landed it's it's like Game of Thrones
you could have read all the books but
still you're like wait which character
is that again like you kind of have to
remind yourself and there's so much lore
it's so dense in a great way because the
details are so specific I guess that's
why people invest so much time into this
into this game you've already seen a
movie yeah yeah okay pretend I know
nothing which isn't far from the truth
uh what do I need to know going in ok so
there's been a common thread amongst all
the bad reviews is that a lot of the
characters are underdeveloped if you're
a Warcraft fan watching this and you're
thinking about going to see movie they
won't be underdeveloped for you because
you put the pieces together in your head
for example uh you know you see the guy
using green magic and then there's blue
magic and it's like what's the
difference
so fel magic is actually this huge deal
in the Warcraft universe because fel
magic is kind of what brought both
worlds tumbling down what is fel magic
it's like demonic magic okay yeah gosh
it's like not not friendly not nice it's
the ugly stuff gotcha is there a good
magic I'd say if we have to say it here
yeah I mean it's it's that's the thing
in in the Warcraft community there's
always like for the Horde or for the
Alliance you know one is considered evil
like the yeah these orcs are like coming
in a sword take but you kind of
sympathize with them because their
homelands being destroyed they're a
little they're like refugees a little
bit they need a place to go yeah that's
not totally an unfamiliar story of
aliens trying to co-opt or terraform or
something another planet yeah to allow
their race to survive yeah no one's good
no one's bad if you're just jumping in
you're gonna see all rights be like oh
they're the good guys cuz all the
monsters are on the Horde but at the end
of day they're just trying to coexist
we're the major characters we need to
know okay so you got Durotan and he's
the leader of the Frostwolf clan this
Frostwolf clan yeah so the orcs are
actually broken up into multiple
different clans but they've united as
the Horde at this point in the movie
Lothar who's one of the Kings like close
friends and he's the main character and
the king is it things that are in the
game that are in the movie is gonna be
Stormwind you're gonna see Ironforge
you're even gonna see Blackrock Mountain
oh yeah it's gonna be there these are
all places oh yes oh wow so strong when
is the human kind of base of operations
goddamn Ironforge is where the dwarves
live and Blackrock Mountain is one of
the first raids in the game lizard is so
involved with the movie and the and the
people who like wrote the creative for
the game have been involved so I feel
like they're really doing a good job of
trying their best to make this for to
not piss off the Warcraft fans if you
were to try and unpack all the Lord
leading up to
this fight if the movie would be way too
long and I can tell they have sequels in
mind so I think they're really trying to
fit as much in the first movie and give
you enough context clues and then when
the second movie comes out then you're
like okay so you talked about some of
the good guys you talked about the evil
fel magic yeah are there any bad guys
that we should be aware of go um yeah I
think in this movie it's the orcs are
most definitely the bad guys from now
you're gonna see that oh they're not all
bad it's just one bad apple who is kind
of like opressing that'll works mmm like
people within the orcs being like you're
the bad guy you're making the bad
choices you're doing terrible things and
it's like well technically that all of
them are bad but then yeah it's like you
see within them is some work on work
yeah problems gotcha
you know I feel like you've given me
that much more of an understanding of
this world so for the uninitiated what's
one last thing you might say to get them
interested or to get them curious about
diving into Warcraft I would say it's
it's like Lord of the Rings like a lot
of people hadn't read the books and it
is an entirely huge world with tons of
characters that you might not know but
if you just give it a chance and you
want to see a new world and you're like
this doesn't have superheroes in it um
it's a whole new world that you can now
dive into so just go in with an open
mind okay if I'm yeah I think if you're
going into this as a neophyte watch this
and focus on the event at hand don't
wait for resolution on who these
characters are because for quite a few
of them it's not coming so the best
thing you can do is really just focus on
the event at hand focus on the
relationships being made and you'll
enjoy it a lot more you guys you got me
a little bit excited for this movie are
you guys excited for Warcraft are you
going to go to the theaters and see this
movie you play the game what are you
most excited about what do you hope to
see what are you nervous about let us
know in the comments section below
and
I want to thank my guests and I both
thank you for being here if he watt away
and Andy before we go so you're making a
documentary about Warcraft yeah yeah
people want to check out the trailer
they can go to Wow mom the movie calm
and I want to make a documentary that
focuses on how gaming actually is a
positive thing and can bring people
together and there's a lot of positive
things that come out of gaming and
that's what the documentary special and
taking solace and gaming and what we
were talking about that escapism yes oh
you guys one more thing Comic Con it's
right around the corner and we are doing
something special we are offering you
the chance to win an all-expense-paid
trip to San Diego to hang out with us at
our super special Comic Con event screen
junkies central all the screen junkies
team is going to be there you could
chill with us hang out have some good
times to go to screen junkies calm slash
Comic Con for an explanation the rules
and to enter then I hope see you down in
San Diego at screen junkies central
thank you for watching I'm Hal Rudnick
hit me up on Twitter bye bye I just
don't want to see another movie about
Eric and Charles playing chess again but
that's the conflict yeah we've seen the
conflict nine times over and over and
over again there she friends we went
from that dude you look like they were
about to 69 each other the chess player
I'm tired of it what about gambit
together